tu veux vraiment que j'arrête le temps
ouais
un
deux
trois
il semble
que nous nous sommes levés et avons enseigné je pense que nous sommes prêts
nous sommes ici pour une adoption
tu peux venir le chercher le 26 si tu
prends vraiment bien soin de lui il pourrait
facilement pendre  pendant des années probablement pas
plus de cinq
nous aurons 40 ans dans cinq ans
c'est tout pour nous je veux dire si c'est notre
dernier mois ne devrions-nous pas bien
ce que ça marche
30 jours 30 danses personne ne s'en soucie
l'internet va être  éteint dans
la prochaine heure nous devrions chercher
des choses utiles mardi ne regarde pas
que
je suis enceinte barry et carrie c'est
sophie salut salut
où sont tes mères elles sont décédées il y
a quelques
années c'est juste le moment avant  tout
s'effondre,
vous ne savez pas avec certitude si cela pourrait
fonctionner à la fin
ou non,
je ne veux rien savoir,
je ne suis qu'un rocher dans le ciel,
si bon dans ce domaine.